okay
um as chair of division two of the house
finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronic
electronic electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
a section of hb2
dealing with the merger of the
university system
and the community college system
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order one
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to extern
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate
in this meeting by the zoom platform or
by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg
dot state dot nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access this
the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
representative petry would you call the
role please
thank you madam chair uh representative
turcotte
representative turcottes at my office in
barrington
by myself there you go representative
petrie i'm here
uh the just a dog today in farmington
uh representative porter i'm here
representative porter's here in
hillsborough i'm alone in the room but
my husband
and cats are in the building
representative heath
murray heath here in manchester at home
and i am home alone
representative murray kate murray is
home in newcastle and
alone representative umberger
yes i'm at my home in kearsarge and my
husband's in the house
and he may in fact join us later on to
listen to
our deliberations today
[Music]
and we are waiting for a replacement for
uh representative lynn
okay um
mickey did you have any luck getting him
i am actively emailing him and i think
he's uh
just having some issues on his end i'm
not
quite sure what they are but we're
trying to get him in here
so okay do you want i have his phone
number if you'd like me to send it to
you
sure okay
okay i can't remember my own name much
less anything else today
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
okay um
at our last meeting um
i had um
requested that representative
turcotte get with
representative heath representative
murray and representative
porter and to
come up with
some an amendment
representative turcotte did that
and this morning i received
an an amendment from uh representative
heath
that we will um also look at
so representative if you could
walk us through
your amendment
i can do that um before i actually walk
you through the amendment itself i just
want to
tell you the process that went on so
everybody's aware
um after uh
you asked us or to put together
an amendment uh what i did
is i started working on that on friday
afternoon into the evening and then
by noon on saturday i sent out the
preliminary draft
in in that time period i received lots
of input from a lot of different parties
i just want and i just want everybody to
know
this is a product of input received from
democrats on this committee republicans
on this committee ccsnh
university system of new hampshire and
governor's office
so i just wanted to make that clear on
when i sent out the preliminary drafts i
said hey
what i'd like to do is anybody who has
any additional input
please let me know by 9 a.m on uh
sunday morning and that way i can
incorporate
any additional uh maybe changes that
might fit the the amendment and i can
say that i did receive
quite a few more bits of input here and
there
up to and including at 8 59 on sunday
morning when
matt called me so um
the document itself the amendment itself
i'll say is a compilation
of all the competing interests and as
everybody on this call is aware there's
a lot of competing interests in this
so what i tried to do is craft a
document or an amendment
that would uh hopefully make everybody
somewhat happy and i knew i couldn't
convince everybody to be 100 happy but i
tried to do that
um
to the document itself um i'll make two
quick
points uh a lot of input that i've
received
since the final one out uh the first one
is on
the april first date
or reporting that would be on page 2
line
14. the document right now actually
shows august 31st that is not what
what went to ols and mickey can
chime in if he needs to but for some
reason it came back as
august 31st that is not what was
intended it was supposed to be april 1st
now i've heard had more input from
individuals about that being too far
down the road
the original hb2
date had january 1st of 2022
and quite honestly i'm not opposed to
that however i will emphasize
that the date in the current amendment
of april
1st is on or before
it's not on it's on or before which
means if the
commission were to come up with
something sooner than that they can do
it sooner than do it uh
you know immediately if they need be but
that date again
depending on how our discussions go
today we can talk about that
uh let's see the second issue
was uh i guess the
the name um a commission i i
i've heard several people mention they
want it to be called the coordinating
council
and quite honestly i i don't really care
if it's called you know a committee
a commission a council you can call
whatever you want
call it potato or doorknob but you know
as long as basically the structure
the structure of this thing is to me
what's important
um so
the reason i did the amendment main
reason
was i i believe that the
the structure of it immediately setting
up a 15
member board of trustees was not
in the best interest
coming from somebody who has not seen
this issue really in the forefront in
public to begin with now that might
just be me i pay pretty much pretty good
attention to
politics and things going on in new
hampshire and it was new to me so i just
think the citizens of new hampshire
deserve a a look at this and that it
should be explored a little bit more
detail than
in putting it in hb2
i'm assuming everybody has had a chance
to look at it
um i can go through line by line if you
want i
i think it's pretty self-explanatory i'd
be happy to answer the questions on it
uh why i did things in it um
you know whatever you would like to do
chairman berger
okay uh mickey can you um
bring the amendment up on our screen so
we can
look at it
i'm going to ask andrea to do that real
quick for us representative i'm still
working with representative merner here
okay that's fine it doesn't matter
i'll bring it up on the screen just one
moment
while she's doing that i will make one
other comment originally
uh when i asked for the initial comments
from all the parties
um they the size of the committee or
commission
the numbers that came back to me those
who supplied numbers were
seven and nine and then i will say at
some point
both uh university system in new
hampshire
and um community colleges in new
hampshire both
uh recommended a higher number and that
number ended up being what you see in
there
at 11 which again i'm not opposed to
okay um is there anyone that would
uh like to comment
on on this
uh amendment that uh representative
turcotte put out
okay i see that uh representative heath
thank you madam chair um first of all i
want to
thank representative turcotte because i
think he did an
absolutely outstanding job in
in putting together this amendment and
it accomplished
a lot of things that we that we wanted
um in terms of
what we saw in hb2 and um the
conversation that we're having now
and i i do also want to say that there
are reasons why we couldn't agree
and sign on to this amendment and
basically they were um
details about membership um time
around timelines about who the members
were so um they just were
a number of things and and in light of
that i want to just say number one
i find this is a far better step
um but we just don't feel it's enough
at this point but again i do want to
thank
uh representative and i'd also like to
mention
um a couple of folks have have gotten
back to me
and they've um had the uh
idea they'd like to see uh four
additional members
on the uh group whatever we're going to
call it
including uh an accreditor someone who
works with the regional
associations i think that's critical um
i
i know that barbara brittingham with um
the new england association i'm not sure
what the new name is called now
um but but might be somebody who who
could provide either a name or maybe
she'd even be willing to help out
um a representative from the 65 by 20
focus group
i think their work has has been um
pretty critical
and i think that's important and i think
they're really critical to the
conversation
so um the original date was january 1st
and we just really would like to see it
pushed out a little bit more
there are i believe about 11 unions
in this process and um just the
complexities
of merging unions and all the details
that have to occur
i just think are going to take more time
um
the other issue that wasn't addressed in
the amendment
is the issue relative to
um maintaining the separate budgets
and and i maybe we're going to deal with
that elsewhere
but i just think we need to be clear
that we we maintain
separate budgets for both entities
throughout this biennium and also
i hope that a consideration can be one
given to funding to support this effort
and then again two
that we provide funding um to support
the um level funding for both
institutions
and finally i just want to say that um
i i have been very
upset about um
the dialogue that we've been having we
have underfunded
our university and community college
system for years
and i just they have struggled
they've had to raise tuition we have one
of the highest in the country
and much of this situation
is of our own doing we're not
responsible for the decline in
enrollment and many of these things
but the situations of the cost of
tuition
that is particularly a burden that we
need to carry as legislatures
we have not done our due diligence for
them
and with that i will be quiet i thank
you madam chair
uh thank you very much representative
heath representative petry i believe you
were next
uh yeah thank you madam chair uh trouble
is the phone keeps ringing
over this issue some of it uh yeah uh
one of the problems i have is a date uh
i've discussed this with representative
turcotte
you know we need to have something in
place uh
probably at least january
and the merger should be on its way by
that time
the money situation uh keeping the
classes separate
i think that's another issue that uh i
i um mirror what um representative heath
just said and also the
uh the accreditation i think that's very
important as uh
representative heath also mentioned uh
and i think we need to work
i think the union situation uh 11 unions
i think that's going to happen whether
you
put it out there five years ten years
two months i mean it's it's it's going
to be a a big issue and it's going to
have to be done
and we expect trouble from that i i
would assume
so maybe not so those are those the
issues i have uh
you know we we need to protect the
community college system
uh but we need to make it a nimble
organization when it's complete thank
you
turcotte yes thank you madam chair
um yeah just a couple comments on what
i've heard so far um
i i i think uh having lived through
several mergers
uh in my job and working for our pilots
union i can tell you that
the union issue is going to be a huge
issue um
you know i'm not going to belabor that
point um
keeping money separate uh totally agree
um the commission
the way it's set up it gives uh you'll
notice on i think it's page two there
begins a long
list of different things they should
look at but it's not limited to that
i would assume that that would be one of
the issues they would
hopefully take up again
representative petry mentioned january
1st again i am not opposed to that
and the last one representative heath
mentioned the funding of the university
and the
community college system that yeah i
mean
although that's a is an issue i guess
it's not the subject matter of this
amendment you know that to me is a
totally separate issue
um so that's what i have for now
okay um represent heath did you have
your hand up again
no ma'am here i just didn't take it down
i apologize
representative murray thank you madam
chair
yeah i really appreciate all the work
that representative turcotte did on this
um it's hard to do over the weekend with
everyone scattered around
but i need to echo pretty much
everything that um
representative he said there are other
things that i think are considerations
in here there's an odd uh
i guess it uh almost a paradox where
on the one hand
this is a committee um which would be
repealed at a certain time i think in
the last iteration it was june 20th
and the problem i have with that is that
i think this needs to be a longer term
however this committee works and
whenever we ask for
work uh results from this committee is
that this to me is more of a long-term
committee
where people have skin in the game where
they're responsible for
some of the work that is done here not
just
responsible for exploring and studying
and assessing
that i'd like to see that there are
people really involved there are other
issues some of them have already been
mentioned
one i think mary representative heath
alluded to this a little bit
but one of the primary tasks
of this committee in going forward in
considering the merger
is to have an evaluation of the
different products that the um
both systems are
producing and also i think it'd be
important that one of the considerations
that they do when they're going forward
is to consider a sustainability model
for these um for the either one system
or the two systems
when the two systems might become one
system but to have a sense of
a real plan around sustainability so on
the one hand
it's i think that what's presented here
is a short
term kind of a bubble
which does not represent a lot of the
things that need to be considered in
here and i'm not sure
about having this committee and then
form another committee and then
i don't know where that goes from there
so there's just a
confusion to me about the way this
has been set up and the way what is
proposed to do
as opposed to what we had talked about
earlier of a committee that
is actually designed to do something
to you know take steps and to be
responsible
for those those steps so i guess those
are my concerns
um it is complicated and um i think one
of the things that we all agree on is
that
this this is going to take some serious
thought
and so this is why those are my
uncomfortable points with this amendment
representative yes thank you um
one of the uh things that was at i added
very late in the game was
uh on page three this on line two
um and that was uh making sure the
commission
is aware of and uh takes into account
the final report of the study group for
post-secondary
education that came out on march 19th uh
just a few you know a few days ago
as i read through that the first six
pages was
was nothing but excellent excellent
questions
without answers because of the timeline
but
i think it uh just shows and illuminates
how many issues are out there many of
the issues that
representative murray and heath has
mentioned are in there
um and again the number of questions and
unanswered questions that are in there
just to me uh
highlights how important getting this
right
will be
okay are there any other thoughts or
comments
on representative turcotte's
amendment
miss provencher you have a question
comment
thank you representative and and um i
apologize if
if the work session uh is is intended
only for
representatives but i i just did have a
couple of comments
um we do agree with a a january first
date to reflect the urgency of the work
and the only other point i would make is
um
i would say a nine-member commission
may be better without the chief
executives
from either system for a couple of
reasons
a nine-member commission
likely may be more nimble but also
the chief executives will likely be
coordinating the staffing of this
committee
working with that any external support
making sure that the committee
has what it's it our commission has what
it needs
to do its work and and the second part
is that the
um the ceos if
representative turcotte's amendment goes
forward would be responsible i believe
it's in this language
for being part of the search for a new
chancellor
if indeed oh am i getting this mixed up
is that not in representative
churchgot's amendment
i believe it's there okay they would be
responsible for
for um uh choosing their replacement
and also the the new ccsnh chancellor
um will be trying to get his or her
feet on the ground and not have context
so and this new csnh chancellor may
also be interested if there were to be a
new chancellor position
in applying for that so um
my recommendation would be to to remove
the chief executive and
from each system and leave it at nine
okay thank you very much
okay sorry
uh yes susan please go ahead thank you
representative on burger
um i respectfully disagree and would
really love to see whoever the
chancellor of the community college
system is serving uh
on this group given how we are organized
um i i don't know that this individual
perhaps if he or she wanted to be a
candidate
for the new search would belong on that
search committee
but i do think that this individual
would be in a place within the community
college system
to comment and to orchestrate the
resources that the committee
might need thank you thank you
representative porter
thank you madam chair um and i guess i'm
confused about
dates here so i would like a little
clarification
if this amen amendment passes
it would become effective
upon passage which should probably be
something around
july 1st given that this is the budget
um
and if we are going until
uh april of 2022
that doesn't give a particularly long
period of time i don't think from july
to april to get this work done
am i am i reading it right are we
changing the date to april
first uh representative would you
mind answering that question please sure
um the date in the amendment
is supposed to read april 1st
2022. you can see the note there on your
screen
again somehow it came through as august
31st i think that's because somewhere
else in the document it uses that same
date maybe i'm not sure but
it was supposed to be april 1st um
again that is a date
was think of it almost as a compromise
state
i was hearing from one side that it
needed to be
into the fall of next year some people
were saying you know keep it at january
1st whatever
and i want to emphasize again what it
says
on or before that means if there are
individuals who think this commission
can get legislation uh up and running
prior to
april 1st that could be november of this
year it can be
december it can be january 1 then that
can happen
it's on on a before date like i say i
was trying to
uh in this amendment to cover try to be
as
uh accepting of everybody's comment as
possible to make it a
a document that everybody could you know
right right thank you it's just it just
seems like the list of things that they
need to
answer and investigate is lengthy
and as you mentioned representative
turcotte that report that came from the
education committee had many many
questions to
probe and find answers to and i just am
concerned that
again it's just as a little too
brief a period of time to do that work
well but i might be underestimating the
ability of the members of that committee
to work effectively together so
i think that um one of the things that
uh obviously
anyone that decides to go on this
committee
or yeah needs to be dedicated to making
sure
that all of this stuff gets done
you know they can't sit around for
months
contemplating whether they should use
their left hand or their right hand
they have to get directly down to
business
and i think that the work
that the education committee did
is a is a very helpful
tool for them to begin to
focus on the kinds of things
that that need to be done
and that um they that
whoever is chosen will
will need to make sure that
this is not just well yeah i need to go
on the committee because
and i would hope that the um
uh the trustees or would the chairman
whoever
would um explain this
to anyone that was selected for the
committee
because we
i know people think we're rushing it
um i know people think
that
we won't be able to give it what needs
to be
given i think that's one of the reasons
why hopefully
in hb2 we will have the 1.5 million
in there to assist the study committee
because it is a huge task
there is absolutely no question about it
and um i think that the
um the outside
group coming in will also hopefully
help to focus
uh this committee
and um you know what
what the right number of people are
is is hard to say whether it's
9 15 or 20
and i think that representative heath
probably made
a very good point that
um someone if we can find
someone from what's it called
the accreditation people and i know they
just changed their names so
at least i'm not sure that they need to
be on the committee
but they certainly need to be involved
with whatever decisions might be made
on this combining of the
of the two of the two systems
um the 65 by
25 group
um i believe has outlined
in great detail what
what they are looking for
in the um
education and i i really
i really believe that that is uh that's
important
and again i'm not sure that
they need to have a vote but they need
to be there
for uh consultation
because i think all of us agree that
none of us have a
complete understanding
of what's going on
at both the university and the community
college
you know the the community college
trustees
are familiar of course with how
they operate and the unh
or the the university system trustees
are knowledgeable about
their operation so it's um
initially i think there's going to be
a lot of trying to understand
what the other system is doing
it's not like they don't have
neither group has the um
advantage of having heard not just
this discussion okay
but for many of us over the years
we have learned a lot
about the operation of both
systems and um so
that's just just a a comment okay
um uh representative turcotte
you have uh yeah i hope you don't mind
uh
i just hear things along the way that
i'd like to comment in regards to the
amendment
uh please absolutely yeah thank you
um somebody mentioned uh about the
selection of chancellor i forget who was
i apologize but
on the third page line seven it actually
speaks to that it won't be an
individual uh or two looking to select a
chancellor that will be the
the job of the commission itself so
that would be the 11-member commission
as to the number of members again i'll
repeat that
i receive every request from anything
from seven to fifteen
um i i think i think eleven is actually
a very good number
you know um the the commission will have
the ability
uh not only to hire um necessary
consultants but i'm assuming the
committee the commission if they're if
you have a great commission they are
going to be using the
or at least getting input from as many
sources as as required
um i i'm unfamiliar with the 65 by 20
group
i think you know getting an accreditor
involved is absolutely
a great idea um but but i'm just a
little hesitant to
start putting too many chefs in the
kitchen if you will
um i think a dedicated group of 11
is better than a maybe a a less
dedicated group of 15 or 21 or whatever
odd number you want to
throw in there and i
think uh let's see
uh oh on the date back to the april
twentieth day one of the representatives
again i forget
who mentioned that um the april first
date
would be a little too quick however i
would suggest
uh you review the the the uh amendment
that
has bit you'll be proposing i think a
little bit later
that has a date on it of january first
also so just something to keep in mind
thank you
okay is there any further discussion on
representative turcotte's amendment
uh represent murray thank you again i
just
had a it just occurred to me i had a
question or comment
um that you know the search committee
selected the chancellor i think you know
that's a
fine idea to have the search committee
select the chancellor
but um you know this committee is
repealed at some time later in the year
and i have not seen a situation where
one could
search and select a chancellor in
that short of amount of time that's
usually a big
job taking i hate to say it
often a year to get that kind of a
position filled so
that also the timeline is a concern to
me
um i agree that they should be the ones
to select the chancellor
but again i don't see that um being a
realistic timeline
just from my experience in that regard
just a comment there
okay thank you very much so uh
could we uh andrea switch to
representative um he's
amendment absolutely give me just one
moment please
problem
welcome to the group troy i understand
you had some trouble getting in
hey thank you yeah i did i had a little
bit of trouble
i'm actually just pushing up on my other
screen for the uh
heath amendment right now
okay well good i'm glad that uh mickey
was able to help you
navigate this whole thing so and uh and
by the way welcome to division two and
um just
a little bit um if you have
comments or questions we raise our hand
and i will um take those in
order of who raised their hands first
second and third
and so that just uh works a lot better
for us i think
okay representative heath i don't see
you
on my screen but i know you're there in
here and
and thank you madam chair i first of all
i just want to again
thank um representative turqart and
secondly
um as i said previously
the pace at which this whole thing is
happening is troubling
and the report from house ed i think
further
uh uh explains the
multitude of questions why so the
purpose of this bill
is really to study the unification
of of the university and community
college systems
and it just defines the members
and again it may it it holds true the
date of 2022
but this is more of a committee um and
it's simply
to look at the process slow down the
process
and to make the determination
quite frankly as whether or not
this is action that should be taken
should should the um
process go forward um with
the unification of
the two systems together what the pros
what the cons are
we have not done the details of
elaborating all of this
we would leave this to this group and in
truth this
amendment certainly needs tons more work
but we wanted just to come forward with
something that
that we felt slowed down the process
um kept the conversation open
but really investigated the report
provided to us
by house education and and distinguish
whether or not
the the order in which
things are going to happen will in fact
take place
um and in fact we would
like um consideration
for this simply as a simple proposal
to say let's talk about this
let's use a report from house ed and we
don't have some of that language in this
this amendment and again i say this
amendment
needs much more working consideration
but
a simplification of a process not going
in with the predetermined
concept of this is a done deal and that
we
are going to move forward forward with
the
merger um this is more of a conversation
about
should we move forward to have this
conversation
and um i look to my colleagues
representative murray and
um porter to add any comments they wish
yes representative murray please thank
you very much
um yeah i think there's been so
there is so much information out there
we've received a lot of information
and in our time frame it's been
impossible at least for me
to go through all that information and
to make some of these determinations on
this
i i'm just overwhelmed with and
appreciative but overwhelmed
of all the information that i've been
receiving um
i've certainly been on the phone with
some people
and they're different perspectives on
this but i think there is agreement that
something needs to be done
and this at least provides a little bit
more breathing space
um i wish we could just go right ahead
now you know and you know get digging
our heels hop in the saddle and you know
get some of the work done
but i think that there's so much
information to sift through
it makes me uncomfortable to try to be
the one to decide which way this should
go
um so i prefer this amendment
i would say that i would like that these
members
to continue in the work because i do
believe strongly that whoever is
involved in this
has to be responsible for where this
goes has to be responsible for
the um the work that gets done they need
as i said before
they need to have some skin in the game
but i think this gives a chance
even perhaps you know for public
hearings to just to hear
from more than what we've already heard
from and to have a chance to go through
the myriad of documents that have been
sent my way not that i would necessarily
be on the committee
but the the documents that have been
sent to us that
we simply have not had a chance to
really review i do want to say i
think that something needs to be done i
don't know what that
is and i would hope to see that this
committee can maybe put
some a schematic a plan something in
place
to help navigate how this is going to go
forward
so those are my thoughts thank you
uh represent porter were you next
i i don't know madam chair
go ahead okay thank you i'm just going
to say that i reiterate what um both
representative murray and representative
heath have said
my main concern with this whole thing
was the speed that it was happening
um seemed overwhelming to me and
the purpose of this amendment i
understand is to slow things down a
little bit
give another group a chance to dig into
this and come back
with a with information that will help
move the thing forward um
i appreciate the what representative
turcotte did i think it was very
comprehensive
um i just think this one slows things
down a little bit and gives us some
breathing room so we make sure we
can get it right when we do it so that's
what i wanted to let just say
representative petry
yeah thank you madam chair um you know
i think this would be still kicking a
can down the road i think the education
community did a fabulous job in putting
their study together
i think we have some good ground work
that we can work with
uh if we push this out to another
uh another biennium i think that's
what's gonna happen and it's gonna get
pushed out again and before you know it
you're
you know it won't happen and uh we'll be
in bigger trouble
are there any other comments
okay um
oh did you want to say something else
represent murray
yeah thank you just then i think you
know uh my
uh representative petry is making i
think a very good point of not kicking
this down the road i think you know
to a certain extent we've already been
doing that and so what i'm hoping from
this group is that this
is a group that will take the take the
bull by the horns
look at what needs to be done and
actually start working on this process
we just i don't think in a way know how
that's going to look
but i you know my hope is that they
won't kick it down that they will have
they will take the responsibility and
get working on this now
that's that's all thank you
okay um
okay uh yeah
mary uh represent heath you indicated
that
um this amendment was not ready for
prime time is that correct
it does indeed need more detail and more
focus but i just want to emphasize the
fact that the real purpose of this
amendment is to create a study
committee not a merger committee
i think that we've got to take the time
to look at all the things that need to
be taken into consideration and i really
think house ed
formulated the questions that need to be
asked
and i think if we could spend six months
doing that
um that would would give us some time
to to really think about what we're
doing
and move forward thoughtfully um right
now
i just i'm really concerned
that we're moving forward without doing
the the due diligence that we need to
do for the purposes
and and for the souls and missions of
either
of each one of our institutions it's
it's a big
step um and somebody's going to
lose missing elements of their programs
and i just want to make sure that we've
deterred and done the least harm
that we can possibly do and to try to
make this a win-win situation
for both entities i would love to see
the university and the community college
agree
on steps to move forward right now i'm
feeling like
there were concerns um deep concerns
on the part of the community college and
and
truthfully we have
the our workforce to look at i i think
that the community colleges serve
a serious purpose in our state
and i just don't want to compromise
either entity so i just think we need
a lot more time so i just thank you
madam chair
uh you're quite welcome um
so if um
if you thought or think this amendment
needs to um
get some more clarity to it when could
you have this back
to us um
i would say um today is tuesday
um we could have something
i think if we work together
this evening we could probably pull
something together
by uh wednesday or thursday
you're making me nervous
i agree um we'll try to have something
by tomorrow
okay uh representative turcotte
yes uh there were several suggestions
that were made
to adjust the amendment that you
produced and
um and in some cases you said it really
didn't matter to you
which way it went that's correct okay
so um do you think you could refine
your amendment to
um make those
adjustments by tomorrow
oh absolutely i can have that done by
this afternoon as long as i
know specifically i heard a bunch of
adjustments and i heard a bunch of
competing adjustments that the one that
i'm
i was going to mention that i think i
will do
and that will be to change the uh
the april first date to january 1st that
seems to be
uh i know that for some people it moves
it up quicker
but looking at representative heath's
amendment uh
again that would only be a um study
committee but
they had the same data in that so i i'm
not opposed to doing that
i still believe april first is fine but
i i can do that
and the only other i'm trying to go
through the issues that were brought up
um really the only other one i heard was
the potential from
for adding an accreditor 65 20 or
something like that but i also heard
opposing views
and i think i stated that i mean
the the commission is going to have the
ability to hire consultants do what they
want and
i got to believe they those individuals
the accreditor and the 6520 will
certainly be able to have the
opportunity
uh to give their input and hopefully the
commission requests it so
if there was something else in there
that i missed that
individuals all agree on that needs to
be in there i'm not opposed to change
that
i just have to have that actually
delineated to me so i know
but but the way i'm looking at it right
now i'm
is the date if there's something else
just let me know
um the
the um the number of
people okay and this is
my thought process
you had mentioned if i'm not mistaken
that
um you wanted two legislators on that
committee
and um i would
prefer that those two people come from
the governor
because we as a legislature are going to
get
our opportunity
to review that and
um i'm not i don't know that you
mentioned
yes you did the higher education
committee
uh that they would report to us
every month i think it was or every
other month
that i believe that that's where
the legislative input will
come from because the people
on on that committee uh
focus only on higher education
that's that's their uh that's their
purpose
and so from my perspective
i would um eliminate the legislators
from that and there are two reasons for
that
number one is
time okay availability maybe the
maybe the right term is availability in
that
um sure over the summer we are probably
more available than we are right now
but as we start getting into september
october and november
our availability drops off
and so um you know we can't
in my opinion we can't have
a a person on this
committee that isn't
that that doesn't have the time to get
dedicate to it
and that's just you know that's my
my feeling i don't know how anyone else
thinks about that or not but
um what i would ask i guess ask a
question on that one would
on this you're you're stating a
preference to eliminate the two
the the one pres uh appointed by the
senator uh the president of the senate
and the
speaker of the house keeping the
committee at 11 and changing those two
to add to appointed by the governor
my initial thought is would it be a
better option in your opinion
to actually change the number on the
committee to 13
keep the two appointments from the
senate and
house of representatives and simply add
two more or do you think
it's just better to eliminate the two
i personally think it's better to
eliminate the two
maybe somebody else has a comment on i
was going to say does anybody else have
input on that
the silence is deafening
okay if if those are the only two issues
like i said i
can have an amendment uh very quickly or
uh fix change this amendment very
quickly that's not a
huge amount of issues
representative porter
thank you madam chair um would there be
an issue with the timeline
for hiring a chancellor
was that a discussion we
had if this is moving back to january
1st
2022 but the this commission is supposed
to work
to find a chancellor
is that enough time i believe that as
written
um no that wouldn't be an issue uh what
the
january first date would be is for the
commission to actually
um produce legislation
whereas the chancellor uh have to find
it in the
um
commission cells serve as the committee
to elect a chancellor or to select a
chancellor
and the
i have to look at it more that would not
be the intent the intent would be
for the legislation to be put forward uh
if there
is going to be any um on january 1st
but the if this commission would not uh
go away until a much later date which
looks like the 31st or something of 2022
so they would have an additional amount
of time to do that
um and i i suppose in fact in the
legislation put forward they could even
delineate hey now we should also uh
select a chancellor so i don't see that
as an issue if somebody has a better way
for me to word that i'm
i'm open to it
uh catherine are you still here
yes i am sorry that's okay
it took me a minute to take myself off
mute well
yeah fine what we need to do is try to
find the buttons
so um generally
we are not calling these people trustees
in in this amendment
so would these folks would really not
have any authority to hire
a new chancellor and like
well well they would if it's in the law
i think
okay mary are you
neither amendment forms a new um
integrated board right it it
one forms a commission and one forms a
study committee but but neither
forms a new board if you will
normally a board would hire the
chancellor but if
the legislation says this commission
would then i
would guess that that provides the
authority to hire
a chancellor
okay thank you i just don't want to get
cross-wise with
uh to representative turcotte's earlier
point
though remember that this commission
working over a six-month period
reporting i believe monthly
to the yes monthly to the public higher
ed study committee
and then recommending legislation
by january 1st of 22
that legislation could change that
authority i suppose if it was the will
of the
the legislators and the in 22.
thank you representative yeah to that
point exactly
again if you read on page three of the
amendment
line seven the commission sells shall
serve as a search committee to select a
chancellor
once legislation has been submitted
once it's been submitted should the
commission recommend a single chancellor
so it that that line right there i
believe takes
answers that those questions
okay thank you representative murray
thank you yeah i have a real problem
taking the
power to hire a chancellor
away from the university system i think
to me that's a bit of an overreach
the university system and the community
college systems
should be the ones to hire their own
chancellor so that's a
that's a pretty big problem for me
cathy would you like to comment on that
well the only i guess i would say of the
members of this commission
eight do come from
the community college system in the
university system
i will to representative murray's point
that this is unusual
that a a commission would
um engage in in a search
but but frankly the whole the whole
discussion
is is um you know unusual we're thinking
about the future of public higher
education in new hampshire
for you know the next number of decades
so i i guess it
it does without some kind of authority
let's just if you please if i think
through the timing
let's say this legislation introduced in
2022 to integrate the two systems
that that would let's just keep playing
this through so then maybe there'd be a
new board established july 1st of 22
if it were to be passed and adopted then
there's going to have to be integration
plans and all of that
and then the board is going to have to
engage in a search for a chancellor
so now we're probably out until
6 9 12 months later before there were
chancellor now
i suppose if again if you play this out
a new board could hire an interim
chancellor while there was a search
ongoing um
but you know the idea to get a
chancellor in as soon as possible
if this is going to move forward is the
in my opinion the the best thing that
that could be done to actually start
integration
if if it's determined that that's the
right path
okay thank you representative heath
thank you madam chair
you know thinking of this
it almost seems premature
to hire a chancellor um
and not having
the university system and the community
college system
um be those driving
that process concerns me greatly but
truly what this project what this
process will need
is more of a cfo or um
a person who is an engineer of how to
make this
work because it may i i
don't think it would be a chancellor
maybe it would be a temporary
um person to bring in place
and they would have the authority to
move forward
but ultimately i don't think we want
that person
to be the long-term chancellor i think
we need
someone that what i guess what i'm
saying is
we really need a project manager to iron
out the details
this is going to be a horrific process
when you think of
all the details that have to take place
so i just think we have to be careful
about jumping to a chancellor
as a first step thank you madam chair
susan yes thank you representative
on berker um the
i think it was the last time that this
group met i
talked about the fact that we are going
forward with a search for
a chancellor with a two-year contract so
the community college will have
leadership in place at least through uh
july 2023
and we chose that particular date
because that matched
the original language that had come from
the governor's office
i agree with kathy's laying out of the
timeline
and also agree with the representatives
who are
making the point that the board should
be hiring the chancellor
so i only say this to give you an
indication that the community college
has people in place
that can continue to lead through
whatever the transition
process is
so if i'm understanding you correctly
susan
you would recommend that the university
system hire a chancellor for
a two-year that
the board of trustees right now should
go out
and try to hire someone for a two-year
period
the same as the community college system
did am i
understanding that correctly no ma'am i
would not presume to tell the university
system
what to do i'm purely speaking about
what the community college system is
doing
we go back to some of my original
statements very different
missions so my comments are only
about the community college system thank
you for the opportunity to clarify
oh come on you you're leaving in june
so let's stick our necks out okay well
yeah
not you know even if i weren't leaving
in june that is not
a block that i wish to put my neck up on
but thank you for that questionable
opportunity
now i it you know this is we go back to
what so many people are saying this is
very very important and i'm going to be
uh parochial and represent the interests
of the community college and say that
we're in a place where we can go forward
with whatever change it is the
legislature
recommends and still have leadership so
that our system of seven
is intact what the university system
wants to do
is for the university system to figure
out but thank you
okay um
so before we before we uh
realized that
that we're uh we're not going to put our
necks on the chopping block
um kathy what do you think
of the concept of
your board or your trustees hiring
someone for a two-year period
and then lynn i will get to you
i don't think it's my board's intention
to hire someone we
we for a two-year period we have a
transition plan in place right now the
duties of the chancellor have been split
between myself and president dean
and so for the interim period
i believe that that will be my board's
approach
shouldn't drink
i shouldn't drink coffee uh represent
turka
yeah um once again i'd like to read the
uh language from line seven on page
three i think this
discussion unfortunately is a little bit
off into the weeds
uh maybe i should start with the last
part of it first
should the commission recommend a single
chancellor
the commission shall serve as a search
committee to select a chancellor once
legislation has been submitted so this
is up totally
to the to the uh decision of the
uh commission that's being put together
um
so i i think the discussion it's okay
but
i think that sentence kind of takes care
of everything people are looking for
what line was that representative it's
uh line seven on page three of
uh the amendment
okay i see what you're saying
okay so um
it appears to me that um
we have no consensus if that's the right
term
on how we should go
i think we have three options
option one is use the governor's
language
as it is option two
is to use the turcotte um amendment
as he is going to
make some adjustments and option three
is to use the representative he's
amendment with some changes
so um
it would it would seem to me
that even though i had
hoped hoped that we could come to some
uh conclusion today and actually
take a vote on something that we're not
there yet
and um i just
uh you know we're not there
and so
uh is mickey
there
i'm here okay thank you mickey um
do we have to have a
finalized amendment before we can vote
on it
or can we have
a draft amendment that would be sent to
ols once we do our voting
that's up to you as as chair of division
two we've done it both ways in the past
so if it's a
a couple edits to a document that
already has been drafted and the
understanding is the motion would be to
vote on an amendment with you know this
amend
this edit this edit to be drafted by uh
our office and bring back to the
committee later we could do that
that's up to you okay
so if we decided to do that
we could perhaps make that
process a little quicker in other words
maybe instead of thursday
we could come back to wednesday
afternoon
i mean i i my sense is we would be able
to
i could work with representative
representative heath and we could turn
around
amendments for tomorrow based on today's
discussion
if based on tomorrow's discussion and
those amendments you wish to make tweaks
and vote on it we could probably get get
through that and do that uh tomorrow
yeah okay that sounds good
kathy you have your hand raised
i think you're much closer together than
than it might appear uh representative
heath's amendment has five five and five
members and representative turcottes has
four four and three and representative
turcotte's amendment
it sounds like was going to change the
date to january 1st
which is the date in representative
heath's
amendment um
so it just it seems it seems like you're
much closer than it might appear
on between the two
uh yes i don't
i don't disagree with that it's just a
question of
how how we want to frame
whatever's going on for the next year
that's that's kind of where where i am
so uh representative heath
i i don't think that we can have
people outside the legislature
without a commission i think that's
kind of how we frame that so
all right yes sorry madam chair
that but that that needs to be a
commission
okay i you know and i know that just
from
years of experience with that i didn't
even think of that
thank you we all have
uh we all have
things that we don't tend to remember
all the time
like um like dates and so on
so okay
um all right i think we will
end this discussion on these two
amendments unless there
is someone else that has
comments or questions
or suggestions
okay seeing none we will end this
discussion uh
mickey oh there you are
um is there anything else that
we could do today
i i don't think so um we're compiling
uh what should hopefully be the uh
last set of amendments proposals from
members of the committee
we're gonna try to get all that compiled
today
and then uh by the end of the day today
i'll have
distributed to everyone it will post
online the amendments for discussion for
tomorrow and potentially thursday if we
leak into thursday
uh so as far as today i don't have
anything
new we we made a we made we're very
productive yesterday to
to get a lot of things off of our plate
and i think the
the final actions at this point for
division two are to be the
ones for um longer discussions for
tomorrow and like i said we're still
compiling those amendments
okay um i got a
update from um representative weiler
last night
uh it appears that the full finance
committee is going to meet on
march 30th okay
for for executing the um
house bill 2. and also
it appears that the presentation
to the um legislatures
legislators is going to be
on april 5th
uh that should be in the calendar that
comes out
um this week again you know those are
our dates that we talked about uh
as i said yesterday things can change
and but as i as i learn anything new
i will certainly
keep you up to date on that
so is there
that you know i can't believe we got
this
not even 11 30. um we probably could
have gone on for
hours on this discussion as we have but
i really thought that it was better just
to
let us move forward with uh with these
two amendments
and we'll see what happens uh
representative porter
this is your last day with us
no isn't that sad i just remember
madam chair i was looking at the list we
worked from yesterday
and when we were talking about the
running start program um the dual
enrollment
we had another amendment that we were
not sure whether
funding was going to go for implementing
you know
for money needed to run the program
and i was just wondering if that's
something we have to re right
is that another amendment i just i
should just ask mary but i'm going to
ask you
that's okay um we will be
discussing that tomorrow okay marjorie
um i uh there is
um i think we had mentioned about
um moving the running start
for dual and concurrent enrollment
into the uh community college and
letting them manage the program
yes we did we did that yesterday but
then there was
a question of whether from the funding
right thank you and so yeah and so
um i think
at least i have a plan if that's the
right term
okay whether or not everyone agrees with
it's a different story but
we i have a plan to put um
would we say mickey a million yes
a million each year into the uh
dual and concurrent enrollment so
that's that's that's what
that's in the works yeah i hated to
leave that little thing up in the air
no no i uh
i'll put it this way you know there
there's some things that
i am really fervent about and that
happens to be one of them
so um you know a lot of
a lot of other things so what
you know but but that is a that is a
program that has
really helped a lot of a lot of students
and um i know
kids that are graduating early from high
school
because of the dual and concurrent
enrollment program
and then they are going on to you know
to college
so it's it's a great program so i'll be
quiet about it
i could i could talk for hours right
shannon on this
okay so 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
and um hopefully we'll
uh get through the things that we need
to
uh mickey do you have a comment no
i'm just going to add that this is
crunch time so if there are any
amendments anything you want to fund in
house bill one or reduce in house bill
one or add in house bill two or take out
anything so now's the time to get them
into me and we'll put them on our
working documents for
the rest of the week uh
one other thing that we have is
sb 82
and um mickey do we need to
take that up before we close out the
budget or
after
it's it's funding for
21. yeah it's um it's
it's actually essentially you can
appropriate the money and spend it any
time but the
nature of that bill is to provide
payments that were based on
fiscal 20 and fiscal 21 kindergarten
programs
so if you recall how the adequate
education formula works
there's a year behind uh lag really in
student accounts for the payments made
so what happens is for districts that
start a brand new kindergarten program
they don't actually see the full
adequacy for those kindergartners until
the following year
senate bill 82 would seek to
provide the money for the back years for
fiscal 20 and fiscal 21 for those first
two years that we were doing full
kindergarten adequacy
so we have a fixed number it's about two
million dollars that would cover all
that uh senate bill 82
passed the senate and has been referred
to finance we haven't had a public
hearing on it so
there was a similar provision in house
bill 623
that we retained and it would be up to
the committee if you wanted to add
language of
senate bill 82 into your budget proposal
and and the funding
okay so we would just um
we would not yeah we would just
incorporate the idea
into the budget is that what i'm hearing
you say into hp2
yeah we could put an amendment in house
bill 2. it would just be carried as a
surplus statement adjustment to
recognize the
uh spending that deal we would make in
accordance with those sections and there
is a there is appropriation language in
senate bill 82 as well to make it clear
how much
is for this purpose okay
so when you have it when you have an
opportunity
uh please take a look at uh at that bill
and um see what uh what the thoughts are
so representative heath i think you were
first
i am thank you very much madam chair and
i just want to say
that in reference to that bill that we
just discussed
i think you will find that the minority
will be very much in favor of this
thank you madam chair thank you
representative murray yes thank you just
so i understand
so this bill has been referred to house
finance so we're not going to look at
this until
after crossover which is after we've
done our work here
is that basically right no
okay okay do correct me
i'm sorry that was um
anytime that a senate bill is sent over
to the house
uh we can begin work on it
okay if you will notice uh in this
week's calendar there were lots of
hearings on senate bills
and so that is uh
if it's come crossover is just the final
date
that all bills have to be sent but they
can be
sent ever whenever then i will print it
out right now
thank you it's pretty short actually
is there anything else that anyone has
okay i think you all want to get out of
here
so please have a nice afternoon i know
that some of you have lots of work to do
and um uh
troy would you mind um
sending me your email sure
yeah i'm at karenberger gmail.com
it's pretty easy okay
so if you if you could do that i'd uh
i'd appreciate it okay
think is there if there's nothing else
then
um we will see you tomorrow morning
at 10 o'clock
thank you all for what you do appreciate
it
bye bye